le destin de l'univers repose sur tes
épaules fais ce que tu veux mais surtout
n'appuie pas sur ce bouton ça fera
immédiatement exploser la bombe et on
mourait tous
allez vas-y répète ce que je viens de te
dire il s appelle rock
non ça c'est le bouton qui risquent de
tous nous tuer recommence à sa place à
belle cote
oui ça paye
à vous de jouer bande de nage
on
vous
tu vénères salve et soan
[Musique]
tiens de la bande adhésive je vais en
coller sur le bouton de la mort non on
n'a pas de bande adhésive
c'est pas vrai yonhap un check la pente
a dit sir bombes atomiques dans ton sac
si quelqu'un te la vente la bande
adhésive c'est bien toi il faut que vous
tapez 2 boulot nous fait beaucoup de
temps
c'est très très mauvais signe
quand je touche quelqu'un je ressens
tout ce qu'il ressent toi tu ressens de
l'amour oui oui c'est vrai je ressens un
amour désintéressé pour tout le monde ou
présent un amour sexuelle a dit ou non à
aa
elle vient de dire à tout le monde le
bruit secrète tout est secret oui je
veux savoir danser avec sa silhouette
avait la haute main parole pas à aller
un mot tout à moi à moi
[Musique]